metal gear survived stacked stiff
repetitive gameplay our top survival
systems that are unforgiving and
unrelenting making the overall
experience feel like trying to break out
of a chokehold with one arm tied behind
your back while exploring the unknown in
search of resources can be gratifying it
always feels like a desperate gasp of
air before the fingers tighten again the
game is set shortly after the attack on
mother base in Metal Gear Solid 5 Ground
zeroes your character is sent through a
wormhole to detail a barren drab looking
parallel world that's made up of
recycled metal gear solid 5 locales
there you're tasked with finding the
cure to a parasite that has infected you
and also seeking out what has become of
your comrades survive story is mostly
uninteresting and its narrative beats
are thinly veiled excuses to repeatedly
send the player out on fetch quests or
to activate machinery
despite some small hooks into the
greater Metal Gear Canon the story is
largely forgettable and keeps out of the
way of the gameplay Metal Gear survives
exploration and resource gathering
routine is dictated by hunger and thirst
which are an ever-present Doomsday Clock
constantly counting down to your demise
and they negatively impact every other
gameplay opportunity survive offers
hunger and thirst depletes so quickly
that micromanaging them becomes an
all-consuming task and because the
economy of resource intake versus
expenditure is way it's so heavily
against you the best course of action is
often to limit engagement with
exploration or combat take gathering for
example this is done by running around
detail in search of dilapidated
buildings to pillage materials from
however sprinting consumes stamina and
as you become more thirsty the maximum
amount of time you can sprint for lowers
it can be topped up by drinking water
but that's ensure supply so in the end
jogging is the smarter option the result
is that movement is joyless and
exploration a chore and this is
compounded when you venture into dust an
area of the map enveloped in a thick
poisonous miasma the greatest rewards
can be found in dust but an oxygen meter
controls how long you can stay there for
all the other games in game currency
kuben can be used for an oxygen boost
you can only do this a few times before
it becomes prohibitively expensive
visibility is also reduced and the map
becomes unreliable so it's easy to lose
track of your objective
cause of all this your time in dust
becomes brief and your spoils are often
feel paltry survive zombie like
Wanderers are usually found in isolated
numbers that are easy to pick off by
simply running up behind them and using
an insta-kill attack their movements are
slow and each one behaves exactly the
same combat as a whole is similarly
lacking in dynamism swinging a weapon
and landing a hit feels satisfying and
range combat provides a little more
freedom of movement but overall it's
more functional than fun
in order to actually craft new weapons
and equipment you need to find recipes
for them in containers around dust there
isn't a way of locating containers
outside of randomly stumbling upon them
and it's a crapshoot as to what you'll
get when you find one if you find the
recipe for a new weapon you'll need to
have the relevant materials to craft
them the more exciting stuff requires
rarer materials which are often hard to
come by if you really want or need an
iron your only option is to keep going
back to dust for short stints in hopes
of finding what you need survive does
make exploration and little easier using
wormhole transporters which serve as
fast travel points however powering
these up for the first time draws waves
of Wanderers to your location to fight
off these moments are when Metal Gear
celeb actually feels thrilling to play
and surprisingly it's because of the
limitations of the game systems that
they are setting up before the ambush
you're acutely aware of how little you
have to work with taking our enemies is
tense partly because of how inelegant
movement and attacking fields you need
to be measured and precise to make each
swing count all the while keeping an eye
on your vitals it's a delicate balancing
act in which the stress comes from
knowing how much you've committed to the
battle and the tension is in how much
you stand to lose
[Music]
base-building is also a big part of
Metal Gear Solid's gameplay and there's
enjoyment in spending time and resources
transforming your ramshackle base into
one outfitted with water tanks areas to
grow vegetables and rare livestock
cooking stations and crafting benches
growing your base is perhaps the most
rewarding part of mell get survive but
the game barely explains mechanics such
as resource sharing and creating
exploration teams and crafting and
building evolve navigating a litany of
menus you can also play survive in
online multiplayer during which you team
up with friends in wave based survival
missions equipment and items are shared
between campaign and multiplayer and
this mode is considerably more generous
about doling out materials and weapons
as rewards this is a good way of making
things a little more manageable but
relying on a separate mode to make the
campaign feel manageable feels like an
obvious sign that the single-player
experience isn't balanced properly for
the most part Metal Gear survivor feels
oppressive demonic and obtuse
it's a shame because there's actually a
good survival game in there but the
pressures it places on you makes
uncovering and enjoying that unappealing
over time the ability to balance thirst
and hunger becomes slightly more
manageable especially if you play the
more you player but the lead-up to that
is debilitating there's some
satisfaction to be had by persevering
and savoring the enjoyment of small
victories but you'll quickly find
yourself thinking if your time would be
better spent playing something else
entirely
until you remember what pain is